foreign
generative AI has emerged seemingly out
of nowhere in recent months with a
notable search in interest according to
Google Trends even within the past year
the spike in curiosity can be attributed
to the introduction of generative models
such as Dali 2 Bard and chargpt however
what does generative AI entail as a part
of our introductory series on generative
AI this video will provide a
comprehensive overview of a subject
starting from the basics the explanation
will cater to all levels of familiarity
ensuring that viewers gain a bad
understanding of how this technology
operates and its growing integration to
our daily lives generative AI is after
all a tool that is based on artificial
intelligence a professional who will
exceeds to switch careers with AI by
learning from the experts then try
giving a shot simply as post-graduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM the link in the description box
should navigate to the home page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered take action
upskill and get ahead what is generative
AI generative AI is a form of artificial
intelligence processes the capability of
to generate a wide range of content
including text visual audio and
synthetic data the recent excitement
surrounding generative AI stamps from
the user-friendly interfaces that allow
users to effortlessly create high
quality text graphics and video within a
seconds now moving forward let's see how
does generative AI Works generative AI
begin a prompt which can take form of
text image video design audio musical
notes or any input that AI system can
process various AI algorithms that
generate new content in response to the
given prompt this content can range from
essay and problem solution to realistic
created using images or audio of a
person in the early stages of generative
AI utilizing the technology involved
submitting data through an API or a
complex process developers need to
acquaint themselves with a specialized
tool and writing application you using
programming language like python some of
the recent and fully operational
generative AIS are Google part Dalai
openai LGBT Microsoft Bing and many more
so now let's discuss chatgpt daily and
part which are the most popular
generative AI interfaces so first is
Dali 2 which was developed using open AI
GPT implementation in 2021 exemplify a
multi-modal AI application it has been
trained on a vast data set of images and
their corresponding textual description
Dalai is capable of establishing
connection between various media forms
such as Vision text audio it
specifically links the meaning of words
to visual elements open AI introduced an
enhanced version called Dalai 2 in 2022
which empowers user to generate imagery
in multiple Styles based on their
problems and the next one is chargpt in
November 2022 chat GPT and AI power
chatbot built on open AI GPT 3.5
implementation
gain immense popularity worldwide open
AI enable user to interact with and
fine-tune the chatbots text responds
through a chat interface with
interactive feedback unlike a version of
GPT that was solely accessible via an
API chargeability brought a more
interactive experience on March 14 2023
openai release gpt4 share GPT integrate
the conversational history with a user
making a genuine dialogue Microsoft
impressed by the success of new charge
gbt interface announced a substantial
investment in open Ai and integrated a
version of GPT into its Bing search
engine
and the next one is bad Google bad
Google was also an earlier Fortuner in
advancing Transformer AI techniques for
language processing protein analysis and
other content types it made some of
these modern open source for researchers
but were not made available through a
public interface in response to
Microsoft integration of GPT into being
Google hardly launched a public facing
chatbot name Google part parse debut was
made by an error when the language model
incorrectly claimed that the web
telescope was the first to discover a
planet in a foreign solar system as a
consequences Google stock price suffered
a significant decline meanwhile
Microsoft implementation of chat gbt and
GPT powered system also face criticism
for producing inaccurate result and
displaying erratic behavior in their
early irritation so moving forward let's
see what are the use cases of generative
AI generative AI has broad applicability
and can be employed across a wide range
of use cases to generate much form of
content recent advancement like GPT have
made this technology more accessible and
customizable for various application
some notable use cases for generative AI
are as follows chatbot implementation
generative AI can be utilized to develop
chatbots for customer service and
Technical Support enhancing interaction
with users and providing efficient
assistance the second one is language
dubbing enhancement in the alarm in the
realm of movies and educational
accountants the native AI can contribute
to improving dubbing in different
languages ensuring accurate and high
quality transition and the third one is
content writing generative AI can assist
in writing email response dating
profiles resumes and term papers
offering valuable support and generating
customized content tailor to specific
requirement and the fourth one is our
generation leveraging generative AI
artists can create photorealistic
artwork in various Styles enabling the
exploration of new artistic expression
and enhancing creativity the fifth one
is product demonstration videos
generative AI can enhance to enhance
product demonstration video making them
more engaging visually appealing and
effective in showcasing product features
and benefits so generative AI
versatility allows you to employ it in
many other application making it a
valuable tool for Content creature
enhancing user experience across diverse
domains so after seeing use cases of
generative AI let's see what are the
benefits of generative AI so generative
AI offers extensive application across
various business domains simplifying
their integration and comprehension of
existing content while also enabling the
automated creation of a new content
developers are actively exploring ways
to leverage generative AI in order to
enhance the optimize existing workflows
and even to reshape workflows entirely
to harness the potential of Technology
fully implementing generative AI can
bring numerous benefits including
automatic content creation generative AI
can automate the manual process of
writing content saving time and but by
generating text or other form of content
the next one is efficient email response
responding to emails can be made more
efficient with generative air reducing
the effort required and improving
response time and the third one is
enhanced technical support generative AI
can improve responses to specific
technical queries providing accurate and
helpful information to users or
customers and the fourth one is
realistic person Generation by
leveraging generative AI it becomes
possible to create realistic
representation of people enabling
applications like virtual characters or
avatars and the fifth one is current
information summarization
generative AI can summarize complex
information into a government narrative
distilling key points and making it
easier to understand and communicate
complex concept the implementation of
generative AI offers a range of
potential benefits seemingly process and
enhancing content Creation in various
areas of business operation so after
seeing advantages of generative AI let's
move forward and see what are the
limitations of generative air
serve as Vivid examples highlighting the
numerous limitation associated with this
technology several challenges arise from
the specific approaches employed to
implement various use case for instance
while a summary of a complex topic May
more reader friendly than explanation
incorporating multiple supporting
sources the ease of readability comes at
the expense of transplant identifying
the information sources so the first one
is when implementing or utilizing a
generative AI application it is
important to consider the following
limitation repeat the first one is lack
of source identification generative AI
does not always provide clear and
irrigation of content Source making it
difficult to trace and verify origin of
the information the second one is
assessment of bias assessing the bias of
original sources use generative AI can
be challenging as it may be difficult to
determine the underlying perspective or
agenda of the data utilized in the
training process the third one is
difficulty in identifying inaccurate
information generative AI can generate
realistic content making identifying
inaccuracy or falsehoods within the
generated output harder and the fourth
one is adaptability to a new
circumstances understanding how to fine
tune generative AI for a new
circumstances or specific context can be
complex requiring careful consideration
and expertise to achieve desired result
and the fifth one is glossing over buys
page it is and hatred generative AI
results May amplify or perpetuate biases
pre-judices or hateful content present
in the training data requiring Vigilant
scrutiny to prevent such issues so
awareness of these limitation is crucial
when implementing of utilizing genitive
AI as it helps users and developers
critically evaluate and mitigate
potential risks and challenges
associated with the technology so future
of gender tvi furthermore advances in AI
development platforms will contribute to
the excluded progress of research and
development in the realm of generative
AI the development will Encompass
various domains such as text images
videos 3D contact drugs Supply chains
logistic and business processor while
the current Standalone tools are
impressive the true transformative
impact generative AI will realize while
these capabilities are seemingly
integrated in the Arabic into the
existing tools with regular use so with
this we have come to end of this video I
hope you found this video informative
and interesting if you like this video
give us a thumbs up and share it with
your friend also if you have any
question feel free to ask in the comment
section below our team will get back to
you as soon as possible and courses
covered in this video link will be
provided in the description box do check
them out thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here